salut c'est jenny et j'espère que vous
allez bien s'est confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs le rendez vous que vous offre
martin la première à la rencontre des
martin vial qui vivent partout dans le
monde
aujourd'hui direction la suisse ont pas
rencontré salim at-il ça me salim
comment ça va alors toi tu es
martiniquais mais tu vis en suisse
depuis combien de temps auparavant tu va
nous raconter l'histoire parce que au
départ n'était pas du tout banni en
martinique d'ailleurs ni en suisse cet
été à saint barth je crois est-ce que
c'est facile de travailler en suisse
parce que nous en france on a cette
vision de la suisse comme étant ben
voilà un pays où tout est bien où tout
fonctionne bien ou la vie
est intéressant parce qu'on gagne
beaucoup d'argent est ce que c'est
vraiment dans la réalité ça la suisse un
peu plus c'est qu'on paye beaucoup de
taxes beaucoup d'eux un expert en suisse
est d'accord fin 2000 euros
[Musique]
moi c'est ça parce qu'on a tendance à
comparer en disant ah ouais mais gagne
beaucoup plus en suisse mais il ya des
taxes qu'on n'a pas forcément des frais
qui sont beaucoup plus élevées aussi
donc on s'en sort quand même tout petit
peu un tout petit peu mieux
on pose des questions parce que cette
émission est aussi l'occasion pour nous
de se dire oh bah tiens si on veut
partir pendant quelques années
travailler ailleurs bon voilà comme ça
ça nous permet déjà un petit peu de
prospecter on sait jamais est-ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de martiniquais dans la
région tuer je crois que tu es du côté
de lausanne
il me semble une très belle région en
plus comment ça se passe le confinement
chez vous ça dépend des pays où on se
trouve on sait qu'en france maria un
confinement qui est quand même assez
stricte mais dans d'autres régions dans
d'autres pays c'est géré peut-être des
fois différemment en suisse c'est
comment
[Musique]
éventuellement plus qu'en fait nous les
français nous dépasser assez facilement
tout est fermé sept mais on n'a pas
forcément besoin de l'attestation comme
en france à des niveaux spécialités
culinaires en semis est ce qu'on vend
bien est ce qu'il ya des choses en
particulier qu'on ne fait qu'en suisse
confidence je serai apte à des poubelles
sont venus s'allume quand on part comme
ça à l'étranger il ya forcément des
choses qui manquent du pays qu'est ce
qui te manque le plus par rapport à la
martinique partie la plage aménagée et
puis même si vous avez des lacs
la température de l'eau n'est pas la
même qu'en martinique écoute on te prend
au pied de la lettre
on passera des concours à j'espère venir
faire un petit tour en suisse en tout
cas on était ravi de faire ta
connaissance de discuter un petit peu
avec toi sois prudent malgré ce
confinement responsable on va dire
et puis on espère le revoir bientôt en
martinique c'est prévu bon bah écoute on
regarde la pâte est salée
du jambon merci beaucoup salim
par cette visite de la chemise confiné
bien évidemment parce qu'on n'a pas le
choix d'ailleurs nous mêmes on est on
est confiné lorsqu'au moment parce que
je suis dans mon salon dont je parle
mais en tout cas voilà ça nous permet de
nous évader un petit peu grâce à ces
rencontres avec ces martiniquais qui
vivent un peu partout dans le monde
merci à toi il ya très très vite on
espère bain pendant ces grandes vacances
même si ça me paraît un petit peu
compromis sinon à noël alors à très vite
salim
voilà peut-être que ça vous aura donné
l'envi d'aller déguster une fondue en
suisse qui s'est bien évidemment après
ce confinement
merci de nous avoir suivis s'était
confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs on se
retrouve très vite sur martin que la
première
[Musique]